2% of black Americans approve of the job
that Donald Trump is doing there are
lots of narratives that are completely
false and yet endlessly repeated by
Donald Trump and his parasitic
bootlickers who hang on his every word
and one of those narratives is the idea
that Donald Trump is just doing better
for black Americans on every metric and
that is a result black Americans support
Trump I don't know more than they did in
the past more than they support other
Republican presidents who knows exactly
what the metric they're using is and
Donald Trump will often count this he'll
say I'm doing better with the black
Americans or as he sometimes calls them
the blacks then who knows who and it's
kind of a weird thing to say from the
outset and the reality is that it's also
not true some of the things Donald Trump
will talk about our black unemployment
wages for black Americans among other
things but we now have data there's a
new Quinnipiac poll that breaks down
this information and I want to look at
some of the interesting numbers on it
now when asked do you approve of how
Donald Trump is handling his job you
will notice that - 2 percent of black
Americans approve of the job Donald
Trump is doing as president of the
United States that's the cell in red on
the chart that I'm showing you on the
screen you might also notice that Donald
Trump's approval rating is only 35%
among women that's the blue say a shaded
cell on the image that we have on screen
and one last notable thing normally
support of Republicans goes up with age
the older groups are successively more
and more likely to support the
Republican right now
approval of Trunk Trump among 65 and
over Americans is lower than among those
aged 50 to 64 notice the green shaded
cell on the chart so a number of
interesting things to talk about here
number one is that not surprisingly once
again Donald Trump's coalition is not
really much of a coalition with the
exception of some Hispanic support that
he's enjoying
about 28 or 30 percent I believe Donald
Trump's constituency is basically
middle-aged white men that is the
primary constituency of Donald Trump and
what's fascinating about that is that
there are groups that are
disproportionately made of middle-aged
white men that are not doing well under
Donald Trump think to Midwestern farmers
historically lifelong Republican
Midwestern farmers who are not doing
well under Donald Trump because of the
tariffs but as I've said before just
because his key demographic groups
aren't doing well as a result of his
policy does not mean that they are going
to go out and vote for a Democrat so
that's something to keep in mind so
let's get back to the black Americans
thing the massive victory with the black
Americans that Donald Trump has been
touting two years now he's been saying
he's making America greater than ever
for black people and two percent approve
of the job that Donald Trump is doing
now we already know what the trumpets
are going to say if you present them
with this information they will say
David that's not because Trump isn't
doing good things for black Americans
it's because black people are on the
plantation they've been bamboozled by
Democrats into being against Republicans
no matter what the Republican does for
them which is maybe the most patronizing
thing that can be said about a group of
voters that they simply don't care what
happens
they don't base their support on what
Donald Trump is doing they just support
Democrats over Republicans because they
are you know apply whatever phrase you
want bamboozled on the plantation
whatever and and this is of course
extraordinarily disrespectful minore zat
black Americans may not support Trump
because of his racially tinged policies
and his racially tinged comments and the
two years of playing coy with white
nationalism
give me a break so the important point
here is trumpets will make a lot of
noise about Candace Owens and blex it
this totally failed movement it's almost
like a fake movement to get black people
to exit the Democratic Party as if it's
some kind of a rational choice to vote
for Democrats trumpets will cheer
diamond and silk these are two women who
are black
and love Trump if you haven't heard of
them great don't even bother to look
them up they are totally toxic and
terrible trumpets will cheer that you
know I don't know ben Carson is part of
Donald Trump's cabinet and then when you
look at the numbers when the rubber
meets the road two percent of black
Americans support Donald Trump the
narrative is false do not fall for it
but do follow the David Pakman show on
Instagram at David Pakman show I also
posted to my Instagram page today David
Pakman I posted a video from yesterday's
twitch livestream where something
happened to my microphone where my voice
went down an octave and people started
calling me David Chad man on stream
that's my latest post at David Pakman on
Instagram make sure you're following me
there we will take a quick break Tom
Hartman joins me next to talk about his
new book out today that's after the
break